[Music]
Canada Alice Burton's old home the
singer then moved to Germany and had her
breakthrough with no roots having lived
in North America until she was 13 she
barely spoke a word of German yeah we
weren't in any affluent er I lived here
near Toronto Ontario Ontario my father
has a loft in nunavut canada my dad
worked a lot and Nunavut were all the
mines own he worked in the mining
industry as an advisor but he also had
to go into the mines and he traveled a
lot after many years and it doesn't
moves Alice Merton is firmly on the
Europe trail with her music homesickness
has never been an issue but one Canadian
specialty can never be too far away
I love making syrup I like putting maple
syrup on everything pancakes crates
french toast - 117 salmon with maple
syrup it's delicious it was also a lager
that might not be everyone's cup of tea
but when it comes to her musical tastes
there is no argument no roads went
platinum in 2017 a success closely
linked to her last move to the German
capital before head snap inning it's
open by mining before moving to Berlin
my music was quite different it's
developed a lot here I always have a
guitar so I'm used to singing and
playing guitar a guitar a spear and I'll
play a bit on the piano - at some point
then I wanted to create more of a rock
sound as a hockey got'em sound
[Music]
[Applause]
a rock sound inspired by Berlin so how
does the music come across at concerts
like here in Lexi she's a great voice I
only know her from the radio so I wanted
to hear her live
I love how she sings because she puts a
lot of power in her songs
Alice Merton likes to fire on all
cylinders and her eight-week European
tour will be no exception she also rates
staying fit to keep up the pace if I'm a
spot I should definitely do my that's
the plan anyway however said so far
that's not going so well I will come
back maybe little change I definitely
have a yoga mat with me you should keep
fit but when you're on stage it's like a
workout anyway work out the way Alice
Merton likes to steamroll through life
it seems like nothing can stand in her
way